this all has largely been driven by
britney spears i love freedom
by the words that she uttered in that
courtroom
brittany posted this video in a yellow
mini dress within hours of her father
asking the court to end her 13-year
conservatorship brit's attorney matthew
rosengard called jamie's surprise filing
a massive legal victory and vindication
from ms spears
[Music]
[Applause]
in the court papers obtained by et jamie
says quote if ms spears wants to
terminate the conservatorship and
believes that she can handle her own
life mr spears believes that she should
get that chance it's important to
remember there are two conservatorships
in place there's a conservatorship of
her person medical decisions who she
associates with etc and then there's a
conservatorship over her
finances britney's worth an estimated 60
million dollars with so many millions at
stake abc news's chief legal analyst dan
abrams says the court may keep the
financial oversight in place but
i think it is very likely
that the conservatorship of her person
could end
that would allow the 39 year old to pick
her own therapist to marry and have a
baby if she chooses when i have more
kids
i would love to have more kids do you
see marriage in the future i mean
absolutely we're a family
what's britt's next move her lawyer says
he's conducting a vigorous investigation
into jaime if they're going to sue jamie
spears there really would have to be
some fraud here remember the court has
been signing off on various expenses
[Music]